[Musique]
hypothèse qui reste toutefois peu
probable Donald Trump dont le leadership
risque d'être mise à mal par son rival
Ron De Santis réélu triomphalement
gouverneur de Floride et présenté par le
miamiéral comme le possible nouveau
shérif du parti républicain les
démocrates évitent une défaite sévère
mais pourraient perdre le contrôle du
Congrès annonce de ce côté le Financial
Times quotidien britannique qui évoque
lui aussi un coût porté aux ambitions de
Donald Trump pour 2024 mais d'après de
spectateur magazine britannique que le
Congrès tombe dans l'escarcelle des
républicains ou celle des démocrates la
vraie gagnante de cette méthode Madness
cette folie des meeters serait surtout
la paranoïa des uns comme des autres la
défiance sans précédent entre démocrate
et républicain qu'on voit emporter dans
une même vague Joe Biden et Donald Trump
compris un dessin signé mortellement et
le reste de la presse internationale est
au diapason
américain le monde relève que les
démocrates vont finalement limité les
pertes même si les résultats restent
toujours incertains au moment où on
parle et c'est le même son de cloche du
côté de d'achat qu'elle aussat le
quotidien panarabe de Londres qui
répètent que la vague rouge n'est pas du
lieu avec cette photo du républicain
Kevin McCarthy il a déjà fait connaître
son intention de briguer la présidence
de la Chambre des représentants au Liban
Lorient le jour titre lui aussi sur la
fameuse vague rouge évanouie et confirme
que les républicains pourraient prendre
le contrôle de la Chambre des
représentants d'une courte tête alors
qu'il faudra sans doute attendre
plusieurs jours voire plusieurs semaines
avant qu'une majorité se dessine au
Sénat elle a eu la photo de famille de
Ron De Santis le gouverneur de Floride
qu'on retrouve à la une très
conservateur ABC le journal espagnol le
présente comme le nouveau référent des
républicains celui qui a défait les
candidats soutenus par Donald Trump la
presse espagnole catalane plus
précisément avec La Vanguardia qui donne
aussi avoir l'un des nouveaux visages du
Parti démocrate un John fait Harman il a
été élu contre toute attente sénateur de
Pennsylvanie face au milliardaire Mehmet
Oz un candidat qui était justement
soutenu par donuts
à la presse française avec un sujet
inévitable la quatrième journée de
mobilisation aujourd'hui en France pour
l'augmentation des salaires on a
l'humanité quotidien communiste fait
état de mobilisation qui gagne et assure
que les conflits liés vous l'avez dit à
l'inflation redonne du souffle le
mouvement social qui parviendra à
arracher dans plusieurs endroits des
augmentations salariales la Marseillaise
quotidienne locale qui soutient
également la évoque on le voit une bombe
sociale qui serait sur le point de se
déclencher avec des grèves et des
manifestations prévues aujourd'hui
notamment à Marseille Avignon et Toulon
et pour finir du foot
les sélectionneurs des Bleus j'enferme
latin Didier Deschamps vous l'avez dit
annoncé hier soir la liste des 25
joueurs retenus pour disputer le Mondial
de photos kata liste révélatrice de ses
incertitudes d'après l'équipe qui
annonce un retour au pragmatisme à
celles et ceux qui néanmoins boycotrait
ce Mondial contesté du Qatar du coupe du
monde de foot dans les Mira je suis
suggérer plutôt de jeter un sida
libération avec ce spécial Libé des
animaux consacrés à nos amis les bêtes
qui proposent notamment de vous révéler
Damien ce que non pas les éléphants mais
les fourmis ont à nous apprendre et
c'est à dire dans un entretien
passionnant avec une myrmécologue c'est
une spécialiste des fourmis et des
tailles quelques
talent des 13000 espèces de fourmis qui
peuple notre terre ok j'ai jettera un
œil merci beaucoup Hélène pour cette
revue de presse